Narrator: As the coronavirus pandemic
continues to escalate,
we are flooded with images
that may be contributing
to our anxiety.
We watch as cities around
the world are disinfected
and get constant updates
on the number of cases
near and far.
When we get away from the TV and internet,
there isn't much relief.
We are faced with closed
offices and empty store shelves.
We spoke to a therapist to find out
how to deal with coronavirus anxiety.
So can you talk to me about
what is at the core of our anxiety
and how does this anxiety serve us?
So, anxiety really is healthy
and evolutionary, right?
I mean, it is there to
say you need to prepare,
you need to watch out,
and anxiety really precedes action.
You know, we would see a tiger
on the savanna or whatever,
or we'd have a lack of food,
and anxiety showed up to
make sure that we acted
and protected ourselves from
whatever that threat was.
Now in this instance, it's
an interesting situation
because we don't have enough information
to really be able to assess
how productive our anxiety is.
We want to find somewhere
between alarmism and nonchalance,
and we don't know where that is
because we don't have enough information
and there is a large
degree of misinformation.
So this is all to say that the
anxiety that we're feeling,
a certain degree of it
actually is really helpful.
One of the things we tend to do,
with any uncomfortable emotion,
whether it's anxiety or
sadness or loneliness,
is we judge ourselves
and then we end up feeling
anxiety for feeling anxious,
or ashamed for feeling
anxious or depressed
or whatever it is.
So in this case,
we want to be able to sort of take pause,
recognize that we're feeling anxious
and make some space for that anxiety.
And actually practice what
we call self-compassion
in response to that.
Those are real, valid, warranted fears.
Now the challenge is a
lot of people, again,
they don't actually go so far
as to understand what their
anxiety is telling them.
They just sort of
catastrophize and ruminate.
And so what we want people to do
is to be able to recognize
the anxiety they're feeling
and then ask themselves,
what's anxiety telling me?
And anxiety is essentially
correlated with uncertainty.
OK, what am I most scared about?
Is it my health?
Is it my parents' or a loved one's health?
Is it my job?
You know, is it the markets?
And then start to really understand,
what do I need right now?
Now, in terms of dealing with uncertainty
and thus lowering our anxiety,
there are two ways of coming at this:
One, we want to be able to
find certainty where we can.
I would encourage people to
find a reputable media source,
check that not constantly or nonstop,
because you will just fuel the anxiety
and it will just frankly be exhausting
and incredibly distressful.
So find your reputable
news source and check it -
give yourself a number of times a day
that you might check it,
and also playing out different scenarios,
thinking OK, if I want to
feel a level of preparedness
in this situation, what
seems realistic, in terms,
of responsible preparation?
Yes, do I want to go out and
but some extra toilet paper
and non-perishables,
or water, or whatever.
If that seems to serve you
and help lower you
anxiety in the situation
then by all means do it.
You know, another thing we can
do to feel a sense of control
and find more certainty around this,
is, OK, are you washing your hands?
Are you practicing social distancing?
Are you doing what you can
to support your immune system
in the event that you are exposed?
And that means getting enough sleep,
making sure that you're
nourishing your body.
Then when it comes to
coping with uncertainty
and sitting with uncertainty,
self-care of course is super important.
So what I mean by that
is doing certain things
that will help bring down the cortisol
and norepinephrine levels
that are stirred up by anxiety,
and that might be something
like exercise, meditation, yoga.
If normally you go to a
gym or an exercise class
or a yoga class,
this might be a time if it
feels more serving for you
to find an app and do something from home.
A certain degree of self-care
is about distraction
and that's oftentimes
what we label as coping.
But really we can't be having
this conversation in our heads
and with others 24/7
because this is debilitating.
Listen to some podcasts
that are on a completely different topic
or watch a show or something.
Try to do something that's engaging.
Try to be present with people
that you feel safe around.
Most importantly too is
still finding connection
while we're practicing
the social distancing.
So that might not look the same
as it would have a couple of months ago
but hey, this may be a time
to resurrect the phone conversation.
Given the severity of this,
how are you helping clients
put some of this into perspective,
and their anxiety around
it in perspective?
Some degree of anxiety
around this is helpful,
so I really do want to encourage people
to not judge themselves for that anxiety
and to allow room to examine that anxiety
and see what it's telling you.
It can be helpful for people to remember
do what is within your control
and also still be able to live their life
to a certain extent.
Just make some changes.